max freed is also one of the game's
great young pitching stars jeff
maybe this is the time for the native of
los angeles to win for the first time in
regular season play against the dodgers
yeah big start for him coming off one of
his rough ones three and two thirds with
five earned runs heavy right-handed
lineup but a good matchup he's pitch
well against the dodgers
as mookie betts slides into the batter's
box to get game three started
and this one's poked towards center and
deep ender going back bud is gonna have
room on the track bets gave it a ride
but is retired
justin turner is the dodger hitter and
challenged the strike zone with his club
popped up behind first long run freddie
acuna is coming in winds going to push
it out to the braves right fielder two
out
and here's chris taylor
this one's popped up into shallow center
ender is there and max freed is going to
have a good start to his day three up
three down you know trevor bauer
obviously likes to go out there has some
entertaining antics out there and the
opposing team they're having fun with it
freddie freeman
freddie freeman right to first base
that's a double play how do you like
that
just love when they listen
should it just be efficient okay how's
one pitch get two outs with perfect
two out spaces empty for aussie albies
in the air to left
aj pollock
side retired inning over
0-0 top of the second larry van over
right here veteran hump day game chip
he's not having any of power questioning
his calls take a listen to this
[Music]
long look in by the braves lanky
left-hander three balls two strikes to
bellinger upright batting stance and on
the ground right into the shift adrianza
with a long throw and it's six up six
down for max freed with three
consecutive ground ball outs
so abraham almonte is the hitter as
tough to hold the baseball in this hot
weather that scorch toward left center
field long run belligerent look at that
ball carry out to the truck at the base
of the wall dansby off of the crack of
the bat he's gonna score and the braves
lead one-nothing on a double by almante
oh baby that ball found another gear and
atlanta's scored first
seven eight nine do up with the dodgers
here in the top of the third with smith
luxe and bauer
little chopper free to the third base
line nice play sets and fires good play
at both ends
and the dodger catcher retired one out
freight has his sign and the 2-2 pitch
is on the way and lux flail at that
didn't get it that's max fried's first
strikeout and he set down the first
eight dodgers in order
and a slow tapper right back to the
mound taking time max
and he does nine up nine down for the
braves left-hander he enjoys a
one-nothing lead so one down and back to
the top of the order ronald acuna junior
cunha down on strike strikeout number
three for bauer
just kind of riding in on acuna good
spot with that pitch and the guy have
even if he had one eye i'm not looking
at the one eye if i'm hitting so that's
the peekaboo
he has the focus and he's just kind of
honing in on that
osceola is hitting third today he's got
a huge gap in left center if he could
split one
he tries to that ball is hammered
bellinger long run he's not gonna get
there that ball is down to the warning
track here comes freddie around there
they're gonna wave him relay throw to
the plate is late
ozzie splits the gap atlanta adds on
it's two to nothing great call partner
same thing with almonte bellinger
playing in the right center gap towards
the braves bullpen
ozzie didn't necessarily smoke this ball
but he put it in the right spot
turner flied to akunyan right in the
first inning oh for one and a great
series now turner hits it toward left
field and that ball is going to bounce
and hit the very top of the wall
and jt cruises in with a double his 10th
two base hit of the season and the
dodgers break up the string of 10
straight set down by max free to start
the game and taylor the batter with a
five-game hit streak the pitch
strike three called inside corner and
taylor didn't think so
so both bauer and taylor have grumbled
today that's freed's third
strikeout as pujol steps in and the 2-1
pitch
got it up a little bit this ball is
flared to right and that's down for our
base hit
and turner comes in to score the dodgers
first run
albert pujols with an rbi
and it's two to one
i think he finds a way
this is what makes him great runners at
the corners with andreyanza at third
base and
contreras over at first
two men out one run ball game in favor
of atlanta payoff pitch
missed
and the bases are loaded for acuna
he popped it up
[Applause]
it's in play for smith
and trevor bauer wriggles off the hook
in the fourth inning no runs two hits
three left now you'd like to get luck's
lefty lefty here one two pitch
didn't matter he got him with the next
one and catrera said my bad larry all's
right with the world three up three down
for freight home fifth coming up
ozzy albe's one for two an rbi double in
the third
as uh all these goes down on strikes
let's strike out number six force albert
pools to do something with two outs and
two on
high fly ball toward left this one ought
to be caught almonte on the run in the
corner he got it right in front of the
stands
great running catch by el monte
pujols pops out and that is out number
three that is a huge defensive play by
almante very tricky maneuvering along
that fence line and the dodgers strand
appeared in scoring position first and
second nobody out here in the sixth
and a shot into right center field base
hit alemante got a late break but here
he comes he will score and atlanta takes
a three to one lead
that's more like it
bowers walk four two have scored that's
the difference in the game
big spot for
aj minter and it will be max
muncie popped him up
ozzy drifts out acuna comes in he says
he's got it he does what a job by aj
minter
two on nobody out for la they pop it up
three times martin gets ahead of chris
taylor the dodgers second baseman the
pitch
fly ball well hit ender going back
checks his positioning hands
on the warning track and martin gets him
in order braves pin perfect six up six
down home eighth coming up the bases are
loaded with no body out and now ender in
crt and company can deliver the knockout
blow two balls in a strike
slice toward left
pollock is there already a tagging at
third there's the catch here he comes
here comes the throw it is gonna be late
ncrt with a two rbi day put it in play
and atlanta adds on
it's a 4-1 score
will smith now gets the ball with a
three-run lead here in the ninth inning
albert
and albert hammers one
deep left
career home
[Applause]
and it's going to be a win fly ball to
straight away center ender camps out how
apropos that two ribbies for render
braves win two against the world champs
jeff they're a game under 500